let me start there with alex caruso
would you take a punch from mike tyson
for a million dollars alex
there's 58 percent of your listeners
that are lying to themselves
no chance have you ever taken a punch
i think the last fist fight i was
probably in was maybe third or fourth
grade so not in a while
uh i tend to stay out of i tend to stay
out of those scuffles but
uh i i i weigh my mental health
i i in dollar amounts i it's a lot more
than a million dollars
have you ever taken a charge in the nba
that you regretted where you just said
oh this is gonna hurt yeah there's been
a couple and some
uh on some some bigger guys uh i took
one last night
even on even a guy named george kneeing
he's just
i just don't weigh as much as these
people you know i look small on tv i
feel
i feel pretty pretty big compared to the
average human but uh
out there i'm the smaller one who came
up with your nicknames
you've got a few yeah i got like uh
an encyclopedia of them uh that i would
say mostly lakers fans
just over those two years on two-way
that kind of started
really this year they kind of just took
off once once i was there full time
they got the they got to see me
firsthand what's your favorite one
uh probably the crucial one just because
the the play on words with
with the name and the late show it's
it's kind of destiny
but bald mama mamba and bald eagle
you're okay with those yeah i mean yeah
what are you gonna do
it doesn't sound like you're okay with
those two i mean what are you gonna do i
can't i can't
[Laughter]
fire dragon or something like that
when did you know you could play in the
nba
um you know i feel like there was a
those two years on two-way uh those
first two years i was on two-way
contract with the lakers was when i kind
of figured it out
uh i would get i would get playing time
here and there
based on injuries or bodies that were
down
just the minutes i was out there i would
have a couple plays here or there stream
together
a couple good possessions and i was like
okay i can do this and then the more and
more i was out there i was just
oh yeah i just get really comfortable
you know you catch up to the speed of
the game and then things start to slow
down for you
when has lebron ever yelled at you
um i don't think so
i i'm that's pretty good yeah i think
that's a good thing i
uh i tend to hold myself to pretty high
standards
so most of the time if if anybody needs
to to correct myself
it's usually me yelling at me what was
your welcome to the nba moment
feels like everybody has one good or bad
um you know i don't know if
actually i have a good one i have a good
one it was uh we were playing we were
playing warriors
uh before they broke up the band and uh
it was
it was clay steph kd
uh and we were playing a game and at
that point our lakers teams
our back court was me isaiah thomas
and uh and zoe and uh we went out to
match up after a time
out and i'm doing the mental check as a
point guard matching up
him him and then i look and i'm like
okay that leaves me with with katie i
look over at the bench like
coach is like just shaking his head
[Laughter]
so i do my normal i pick up a like full
court just give a little token pressure
and he can bounce the ball and kind of
looks around
and he like realizes that i'm guarding
him and he's like hey man give me the
ball
[Laughter]
wait did he say it out loud or just
uh i will say i held my own he went one
for two hit a tough shot and then i got
turned over so i feel like that was
a pretty neutral uh neutral encounter
yeah but you
were a really good defender in college i
mean you came out a lot of steals and
i mean in my opinion i'm a really good
defender now too
well i don't know if anybody's a real
good defender in the nba it feels like
the way these guys score right yeah
who has who's that tough matchup though
when you go oh
this is not going to be fun i mean you
got the easy ones right like uh
like harden you know i mean the stuff
the stuff you can do with the basketball
is so underappreciated
he's so good at scoring it's it's almost
like
people root against him just because
he's so good it's like
what do you want to make him do alex
you can't let him shoot threes if you
let him shoot threes he's going to put
60 on you you know we've seen that so
many times and it's
and it's a lot easier to say that than
to do that
yeah uh but but you know i think you
just i think you got to live with him
get into the paint and either creating
for others or
taking those little tough mid-ranges or
floaters which he's more than capable of
making and getting to 36 almost 40
points so
it's a it's kind of a lose-lose you just
try to do your best and
and frustrate him sometimes and he's so
physical too
i think that's what people don't realize
i mean you know it's it's a tough thing
he's six seven and you he makes the step
back just like a normal catch and shoot
jumper for most people so uh
yeah that's really that's a really tough
one dame's a tough one dane so
uh his range is unlimited and then he's
really really really really quick so uh
those two are tough and the obvious ones
that you know kawhi
uh even even paul george i mean most of
these guys that are tough to guard
they're the ones that can shoot from
30 feet but also take you to the rim who
talks the most to you
you know i really don't i really don't
hear
too much jabber you know
at least at least not towards me i'm not
a i'm not a trash talker myself
once uh about halfway through my college
career i kind of i kind of
dialed back on that because it was
slowing me down
i didn't have a i didn't have a very
good mental uh mental edge on people
when i was trying to i was trying to
talk trash i'm not
not a guy who can perform and do that so
i'm
i'm gonna hike my teammates up and stay
in my lane kind of person now
he's alex caruso the lakers guard he is
uh partnering with
um small stars and it's uh
they have a new short that came out taco
tuesday where his
small stars teammate joined a teammates
joining for a
weekly meal in fun uh the shareable
video here explain what you're doing
with this
yeah so basically uh have a little fun
with the uh
the play on taco tuesday i'll have a
video out on my socials later today
that'll uh
that'll explain it all a lot better but
small stars basically just
it's the the 21st century collectible
right it's a
it's a foot tall uh it has a little
magnetic basketball it's bigger than
than your your normal collectible item
or bobble head or anything like that
i have a couple of them that they they
sent me and when i first
took it out of the box i was surprised
at how big the actual
collectible was but it's just a really
really cool way
for for basketball fans fans of the nba
you
you see your favorite player a.d uh
braun i think dame and giannis are the
other ones that they're they're starting
out with
just a really cool thing to kind of kind
of show your fan though
i want the i want the caruso bobble head
doll
we're working on it we're working on it
i'm crossing my fingers we might get one
done
now does lebron know that you've uh
hijacked taco tuesday
um i don't think he did i think i
borrowed it i wouldn't say hijacked
well i'm gonna leave that up to you when
you tell to lebron because
technically his collectible was at
dinner so you know it's like part of him
was was there too so we got the release
basically you missed your sister's
wedding because
of course we're in the bubble what do
you get your sister when you miss her
wedding
uh championship there you go that's what
i said
that's that's right yeah
that's the best gift you can give her
get her on the get her on the bus in the
parade and
we'll call it even uh could you
answer this honestly even though you're
his teammate if i said who's the mvp of
the nba
this season you kind of loaded that
question huh i would say lebron
well okay if i took lebron off the
ballot then
if it's not if it's not lebron i think
it'd have to be giannis
okay i think i think giannis is a is a
phenomenal player you know the stuff he
does night and night out
uh he's he's the mismatch i think that's
the way the league's going where you
have a big
six nine to seven foot wing or post that
can
handle shoot get to the rim playmake i
think that's what the league's turning
into
even i mean you see it we got two of
them on our team in 80 and lebron
and that's a luxury to have but every
team has to have one now
you know he's doing it at the highest
level and lebron at his age
and i had damian lillard on a couple of
weeks ago and he said he's still the mvp
you know he's not what he once was
physically but he is so smart
what is it about him that you're on the
floor with him that he has this
basketball iq that's through the roof
he just i i've always prided myself
in having a basketball iq where i've
been a real heady player and i can kind
of see plays develop before they happen
um
being around him and uh especially him
but also
rajon rondo those two guys on the same
team man it's
some of the film sessions and some of
the conversations they have in practices
or shoot arounds about
how you want to position somebody or put
somebody in a certain place on a play
they
they see stuff on a different level you
know it's been a it's been awesome for
me to just be their teammate and see
that process
and see how they mentally work through
stuff
just because i'm such a basketball
junkie you know that kind of stuff gets
me excited
uh but but yeah you can't even you can't
even speak to how he's playing it at his
age but then you
match that with how smart he is i think
that's how he's able to keep doing it
what's the story you're gonna tell your
grandkids or kids
about lebron probably his work ethic
probably probably how uh that's that's
gonna be my like
my my pillar as a as a father is work
hard and you can achieve what you want
because i can't i feel like that's kind
of how i got to the nba and how
i'm planning on staying here is working
through it and
being around him that dude that do works
more than anybody i know
it's it's you see him first in the gym
last to leave he's getting treatment
stuff like that
uh that's that's who he is have you been
invited to his house for taco tuesday
we have not been over to the house
we've been a little busy oh quarantine
oh i know but
prior to quarantine he had taco tuesdays
and
you never know never made the cut okay
oh yeah
i'm gonna cross my fingers i'm gonna
send him a text today and let him know
i'm upset
what do you do today you don't have a
game till tomorrow
yeah we uh hang out you know i might
might go hit some golf balls at the
range uh we
got a team meeting late this afternoon
so uh
it's kind of fun stuff to do you know
play xbox with the teammates
it's it's uh before we started playing
games i would i would for sure go out
and play
a four round of golf maybe uh maybe a
second one but you know we got back to
back coming up i'm gonna
dial it back lebron play golf
i don't think so i don't uh we got a
couple guys on the team that are trying
to get into
get into the game uh i played with
played with jr a lot jared
is really good but i know i know cruz
and javale have both told me they want
to go to the range
those are some guys i'm worried i'm
worried about javale
mcgee on the driving range alex you'll
probably see it in the next vlog
uh give the uh pitch one more time for
taco tuesday let people know about it
soccer tuesday so i'm doing the video
it'll be out on my socials
uh later today and it's just it's just a
fun little uh
little gap about me and the small stars
coming out my my two teammates anthony
davis lebron james
um are these replicas these ginormous
red plays and it's just it's just a fun
video kind of promo in the uh the small
stars campaign coming up
well congrats it's been a fun ride here
i'm sure for you and
uh good luck the rest of uh the pandemic
i appreciate that we're we're gonna have
a lot of fun with it it's uh
it's interesting but we're gonna get
through it thank you alex
i appreciate you having me on that's
alex caruso the lakers guard